Ich bin der Diensthabende Arzt und würde jetzt gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Popol Bakh.
Könnten Sie das langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja, mein Vorname ist P-O-PP-L-E.
Und Nachname buchstabiert sich B-A-C-H.
Ja, wie alt sind Sie?
55 Jahre alt bin ich.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
18.04.1973
19...1973...60 oder?
70.
Danke.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,81 Meter.
1,81 Meter. Okay. Wissen Sie, wie viel Sie wiegen?
Ich denke 74.
74. Okay. Was würdest du heute zu uns geben? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Herr Bach?
Herr Doktor, seit heute Morgen habe ich Luftnot und eine starke Hust.
Luftnot und starke Husten haben Sie?
Ja, ich fühle mich nicht so gut.
Unter Luftnot leiden Sie jetzt oder?
Nein, das ist ganz normal. Momentan ist es gut.
Es ist Zeit, aber heute Morgen haben Sie darüber gelitten.
Heute Morgen.
Okay.
Ja, wir gehen zuerst zu Luftnot.
Herr Bach, sind Ihre Atemnot oder Luftnot flüssig oder langsam aufgetreten?
In der Nacht oder zum Beispiel heute Morgen kommt es ganz flüssig.
Flüssig.
Und in der Atakanweise dauert es ca. 50 Minuten.
Die Atemnot kommt in Anfällen.
Wie gesagt, dauert es ca. 50 Minuten.
Ca. 50 Minuten dauert die Atakan.
Okay. Wie oft hatten Sie Atakan bis jetzt?
Ja, ich weiß es nicht ganz genau, aber seit drei Wochen habe ich ähnliche, aber leichte Symptome.
Aber seit heute Morgen habe ich ein bisschen schlimmer geworden.
Ja, es gibt mir vielleicht, dass Sie das erleben mussten.
Aber seit drei Wochen haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden, aber leichter.
Ja, besonders morgens früh oder in der Nacht beim Schlafen.
Welches ist stärker, morgens früh oder in der Nacht?
Egal, beides gleich.
Okay.
In welcher Situation sind die Beschwerden aufgetreten?
Sind diese Atemnot aufgetreten?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, ich weiß es nicht fast genau, aber es ist nicht belastungsabhängig.
Nicht belastungsabhängig?
Ja, ich bin in Ruhe.
Im Bett kommt mir ein Anfall.
Gleichzeitig muss ich auch...
Ja, ich weiß es nicht, warum kommt es.
Zum Beispiel gestern Abend habe ich ähnliche Symptome und heute Morgen, aber jetzt bin ich ganz gut.
Okay. Haben Sie während der Atakan Pfeifendatengeräusche, Bema?
Oder sind Ihnen Gehmen oder Brümen aufgefallen?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Okay. Meinen Sie mit ein bisschen? Ja?
Ja. Teilweise.
Könnten Sie flach liegen oder brauchen Sie zum Schlafen mehrere Kissen?
Besonders nach einem Tag zum Beispiel.
Ja, ich brauche nie mehrere Kissen beim Schlafen.
Ich bin ganz normal. Ich weiß es nicht, warum kommt es, diese Anfälle?
Vor drei Wochen habe ich gar nicht ähnliche Beschwerden.
Okay. Sie werden das entdecken.
Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorge. Sie sind in guten Händen und wir werden unsere Beste für Sie tun, Herr Bach.
Herr Bach, ich komme zu Ihren Hüsten.
Sie haben aber schon gesagt, dass Sie Hüsten haben.
Könnten Sie mir sagen...
Oder könnten Sie den Hüsten genau beschreiben?
Zum Beispiel, ist er trocken oder haben Sie einen Auswurf?
Ja, Herr Doktor, ganz, ganz stärker Hüsten, aber ohne Auswurf.
Ohne Auswurf? Ja, ganz, ganz trocken.
Ich habe mir einen Kratzen im Hals oder in meinen Lungen.
Wie bitte? Kalt?
Ich habe einen Kratzen in meinem Hals.
Okay. Ja, Frau Bach, Entschuldigung, Herr Bach, haben Sie Beschimpftauslöser für Ihre Beschwerden bemerkt?
Beschimpftauslöser habe ich nicht bemerkt. Aktuell noch nicht. Aber keine Belastung abhängig.
Aber ich habe bemerkt, dass es mir sehr gut geht.
Tagsüber bei der Arbeit habe ich keine Probleme.
Keine Probleme?
Bei der Arbeit keine Probleme, nur zu Hause.
Okay, das ist auch für mich sehr wichtige Information. Danke für das.
Okay. Haben Sie Brustschmerzen, Engelgefühl oder Herzrasen?
Während der Attacke habe ich ja.
Sobald, entweder während der Attacke oder ohne Attacke?
Momentan, im Moment, ich bin ganz, ganz normal.
Aber während der Attacke habe ich Herzrasen, ein bisschen Müdigkeit und nicht so stark, aber Brustschmerzen habe ich.
Brustschmerzen?
Ja, ja. Nicht so stark, nicht so schwer, aber habe ich.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Streschendurrent, drückend oder dumpf?
Ja, ein bisschen dumpf, nicht drückend, aber ich fühle mich nicht so gut.
Wie stark?
Das ist meine Stärke Schmerzen. Wie ein Gefühl.
Wie ein Engelgefühl?
Ja, ja. Engelgefühle haben besser.
Danke für diese Information. Haben Sie Fieberstelle für Nachtschweiß, Kaltenschweiß?
Ja, genau so. Wegen der nächtlichen Attacke habe ich nur ein bisschen Schlafstörungen, aber andere Beschleunigung.
Nein, nein. Ich meine Fieberstelle für Nachtschweiß.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Aber Sie leiden unter Schlafstörungen wegen dieser Attacke?
Ja, ja. Ich habe keine Luft bekommen.
Okay. Und haben Sie Übelkeit oder müssen Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, sowas habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ganz gut.
Und haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ungewollt oder zu genommen, Herr Bauch?
Sowas habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Gibt es noch etwas, das Sie hinzufügen möchten oder wollten?
Ja, ich habe...
Entschuldigung, ich habe noch ein paar Fragen. Entschuldigung, Herr Bauch.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt. Ja, ganz normal.
Okay. Was ist mit dem Stuhlgang?
Auch normal, ja.
Okay. Entschuldigung.
Okay. Herr Bauch, gibt es Ihnen...
Gestern haben wir schon mal gegen Stärkefüße. Ich nehme mir einen Pfüstensaft.
Ganz glanzlich angenommen, aber das kann nicht...
Pfüstensaft.
Das kann nicht sein.
Könnten Sie den Namen des Pfüstensaftes nennen?
Oder erinnern Sie sich daran?
Ich denke, Fenchelhörnig-Schub.
Wie bitte?
Fenchelhörnig. Flaslische.
Flaslische. Okay.
Okay. Nur gestern oder heute auch.
Gestern.
Haben Sie eingenommen.
Gestern. Aber das hat Ihnen nicht geholfen.
Ja.
Herr Bauch, gibt es in Ihrer Vollgeschichte Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, zum Beispiel chronische Erkrankungen wie Bluthochdruck oder erhöhte Blutwertwerte?
Seit drei Jahren habe ich eine Reissdarm-Syndrom. Bei mir bekannt. Reissdarm-Syndrom.
Wenn ich Stress habe, dann kommt mir eine Magenschmerzen und manchmal Durchfall.
Durchfall. Okay. Und Bauchschmerzen.
Ja. Aber außer ganz normal.
Okay. Noch etwas?
Und circa vor zehn Jahren.
Ja.
Das war bei mir. Ich habe eine Gelbsucht bekannt.
Gelbsucht. Nach einer Reise oder?
Ja, ja. Wir haben mit allen Freunden und Freundinnen nach Brasilien reist.
Und da haben Sie bekommen?
Ja, da haben wir alle bekommen. Gelbsucht. Jede circa zwei Personen.
Danke für diese Information. Herr Bauch, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Operationen? Ja.
Welche Operationen hatten Sie?
Mit sieben wurden mir Mandeln entfarrt.
Ja. Noch etwas?
Und mit zwanzig bei mir eine Brindarm entfarrt.
Waren die Operationen komplikationslos?
Ja, ich denke, das war komplikationslos.
Okay. Das ist schön. Außer Hustensaft nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme regelmäßig gegen mein Reissdarm-Syndrom Chimea.
Chimea. Ja, ja. Chimea.
Bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig?
Ich nehme regelmäßig, ja.
Aber ich denke, Sie brauchen nicht Chimea einzunehmen, wenn Sie keine Beschwerden haben.
Sie können einfach bei Bedarf nutzen oder einnehmen.
Aber Chimea ist wie ein Vitamin, ein ganz von anstlichem Produkt.
Ah, als Vorbeutung. Okay. Das habe ich verstanden.
Das ist gefährlich, ja.
Okay. Das habe ich verstanden.
Ich habe das meinem Haus geraten und er sagt, kein Problem.
Ja, noch etwas?
Ähm, noch andere Medikamente habe ich nicht.
Okay. Sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt, Herr Bach?
Wir haben viele Beispiele.
Ja, aber soweit ich weiß, als Kindheit habe ich eine Katzenhaareallergie.
Damals hat mein Vater mir eine Katze gegeben und dann war mir das ein bisschen schwieriger.
Okay. Wie hat sich Ihre Allergie geäußert?
Erinnern Sie sich daran?
Ja, soweit ich weiß. Ich reagiere sehr, sehr schlecht mit Atemnot.
Ja, Kratzen, Tabakgefühl.
Okay. Herr Bach, danke für die Informationen.
Herr Bach, darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen oder ob Sie früher geraucht haben?
Ich habe nicht raucht.
Sehr gut.
Ich bin nicht raucht, ja.
Sehr gut. Ich gratuliere Ihnen. Trinken Sie Salkot?
Gerne. Ein oder zwei Gläser Wein am Wochenende.
Okay. Also, Herr Bach, routinemäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie mit irgendwelchen Drogen Kontakt haben.
Warum fragen Sie danach?
Wie gesagt, ist das eine Routinefrage und wir sollten wissen, dass manche Drogen oder Medikamente nebenwirkungen haben.
Deswegen habe ich danach gefragt.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich bin nicht Raucher.
Ich meine nicht Raucherin. Ich meine Drogen.
Niemals.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja.
Treiben Sie Sport? Regelmässig Sport?
Nein, ich habe keine Zeit für den Sport.
Haben Sie Haustiere zu Hause oder bei der Arbeit?
Ja.
Was für ein Tier haben Sie?
Wir haben einen Hund, einen kleinen Hund.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen.
Jetzt würde ich Ihnen gerne einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen. Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Meine Vater ist letztes Jahr wegen einer Bronchelkarstnur verstorben.
Es tut mir leid, dass Sie hören, Herr Bach.
Was ist mit Ihrer Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat Asthma. Aber sie ist gesund.
Sie nimmt ihre Medikamente regelmäßig.
Aufmerksamkeit.
Sie hat keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Er hat eine Nierenversorgung.
Er muss in der Woche mindestens dreimal zum Blutwäsche gehen.
Für die Blutwäsche zum Krankenhaus.
Ich weiss nicht, was Blutwäsche ist.
Warum ist mein Bruder mindestens zwei Mal ins Knochen ausgeht?
Blutwäsche, auch Dialys genannt, ist eine Ersatztherapie bei Nierenversorgung.
Wenn die Nieren nicht gut funktionieren, ist eine Alternative für uns als eine Therapie Blutwäsche.
Höchstwahrscheinlich hat Ihr Bruder Nierenversorgung, Herr Bach.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Leider haben wir keine Kinder. Wir möchten ein Kind bekommen.
Aber wir können es bis jetzt nicht bekommen.
Meine Tochter hat gesagt, eine IVF.
Ich weiss nicht genau, was das ist.
Eine künstliche Befristung.
Deswegen nehme ich für meine Frau eine Labrador, einen kleinen Hund, für sie als Geschenk.
Wann haben Sie den gekauft?
Vor einem Monat.
Ich hoffe, Herr Bach, Sie können auch ein Baby haben.
Manche Leute versuchen diese Therapie viele Male und bekommen dann ein Kind.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Bach?
Ich bin IT-Techniker.
Herr Bach, ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Offenheit und Ihr Geduld.
Ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Asthma, die Ihre Mutter und vielleicht aufgrund Ihres neuen Hunds.
Aber das bleibt nur eine Vermutung.
Deshalb müssen wir weiter durchführen, um das zu bestätigen.
Zunächst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Ihnen anschließend etwas Blut abnehmen für das Labor.
Danach werde ich einen Lungenfunktionstest und einen Prick-Haut-Test durchführen.
Dann werde ich einen Lungenrunken veranlassen.
Sobald Ihre Befunde vorliegen, bespreche ich alles mit meinem Oberarzt.
Danach komme ich zu Ihnen zurück und erkläre Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es weitergeht.
Ja, okay. Aber ich möchte nie einen Lungenrunken bekommen.
Aber Sie bekommen...
Das ist nicht so gefährlich, wie Sie denken oder wie Sie Angst haben, Herr Bach.
Es sind halt so niedrige Strälen und so viele Strälen können den Körper nicht schäden.
Nicht schädlich, ja?
Ja.
Okay, vielen Dank. Ich warte auf Sie.
Okay. Warten Sie auf mich.
Kling-Kling.
Dr. Doan Amaparat, bitte.
Guten Tag. Ich bin Frau Müller aus dem Labor.
Frau Clemens' Thrombocyt-Werte sind 16.550.
Wie viel sind das? 16.000?
16.550 pro Mikroliter.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Werte Ihren Oberarztin weiterleiten?
Ja, okay. Ich kann das machen. Aber könnten Sie die Name wiederholen?
Frau Clemens mit C L E M E N Z.
Okay, danke. Ich mache das.
Danke sehr. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Okay. Was ist Ihr Nachname?
Cetin Abi.
Ja, Cetin Doan.
Okay. Herzlich willkommen Herr Doan.
Danke.
Woher kommen Sie?
Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit wann sind Sie in Deutschland?
Ich bin seit mehr als 2,5 Jahren in Deutschland.
Okay. Warum sind Sie nach Deutschland gekommen?
Ja, ich musste nach Deutschland kommen.
Ich konnte in der Türkei nicht meinen Beruf ausüben.
Deswegen musste ich die Türkei verlassen.
Und für mich ist Deutschland die beste Alternative in Schia.
Darf ich fragen, warum konnten Sie Ihren Beruf in der Türkei ausüben?
Wegen politischen Gründen konnte ich nicht das schaffen.
Ja, ich kenne diese Situation. Machen Sie sich gleich fragen.
Das ist ein bisschen komplizierter. Ich möchte ausführlich erzählen, aber vielleicht später.
Sie müssen nicht ausführlich erklären.
Okay. Was haben Sie bisher in Deutschland gemacht?
Bisher habe ich intensiv Deutsch gelernt.
Parallel dazu bin ich mit manchen ehrenamtlichen Aufgaben beschäftigt.
Welche ehrenamtliche Arbeit sind Sie beschäftigt?
Es geht um die Integration.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen? Momentan versuchen wir ein bisschen spontan zu sprechen.
Ich bin Mitglied eines Vereins.
Dieses Vereins ist beschäftigt mit den Immigrationproblemen.
Es geht um die Betroffenen, besonders natürlich für Flüchtlinge und Kinder.
Und auch ich.
Okay. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Guten Tag, Frau Oberstin. Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstellen möchte, möchte ich Ihnen etwas wichtiges mit teilen.
Ich habe einen Ruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Ich soll Ihnen sagen, Frau Clemens hat einen Thrombocytin-Werte von 18.550 pro Mikroliter.
Dieser Werk ist stark ermieden und entspricht Thrombocytopenie.
Weil Sie dafür zuständig und verantwortlich sind, möchte ich Ihnen darüber informieren.
Wissen Sie, welche Ursache eine Thrombocytopenie verursachen kann?
Ja, die häufigsten Ursachen gehören zu Leukemin,
Plastik, Thrombocytopenie, Immunthrombocytopenie und auch Heparin-Induzierte Thrombocytopenie oder Hypersyplenismus.
Solche können Thrombocytopenie häufig verursachen.
Okay. Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Thrombocytopenie?
Natürlich ist dieser Wert sehr lebensbedrohlich und gefährlich.
Die Patienten mit diesem Wert haben einfach lebensbedrohliche spontanen Blutungen.
Weil dieser Wert unter 20.000 pro Mikroliter ist?
Ja, unter 20.000 oder 15.000 Mikroliter kann eine spontane Blutung entstehen.
Sie haben recht, aber ich habe gefragt, welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Thrombocytopenie?
Okay, unter diesem Wert ist eine Schwere.
Deswegen kann ich sagen, dass solche Schwere auch in einer Blutung,
beispielsweise in einer Gastrointestinal-Tratak oder im Gehirn, auftreten können.
Ich meine allgemein nicht unter diesem Wert, zum Beispiel Nasenblutung, Sandfleischblutung, Hämatom, PtSCHI.
Ich möchte alle Symptome hören, aber das ist auch nicht falsch.
Ich habe gedacht, dass dieser Wert besonders diese Schwere erwarten.
Okay, wie können Sie Thrombocytopenie behandeln?
Ich kann Thrombocytophen konstant werden.
Bei starken Blutungen oder sehr niedrigen Thrombocytophen werden,
muss man Thrombocytophen konstant werden.
Aber Hauptsache ist, die Gründe zu behandeln.
Es gibt viele Gründe, zum Beispiel Leukämie oder Immuntrombocytopenie oder Heparin-industrieierte Thrombocytopenie.
Wenn die Ursache dafür Heparin ist, muss man das Heparin sofort absetzen.
Wenn die Ursache Immuntrombocytopenie ist, muss man mit Cortisol oder mit IV Immunoglobulin behandeln.
Okay, das ist genug. Was haben Sie noch?
Frau Bojarsdyn, wie gesagt, habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Jetzt vorstelle ich diesen Patienten.
Ich habe es mir gedacht.
Gute Besuchung.
Danke.
Es geht um Hopplebach.
Er ist 55 Jahre alt, geboren am 8.04.1973.
Er ist 1,81 Meter und wiegt 74 Kilo.
Er kam heute zu uns, weil heute Morgen aufgetretene Düspne und trockenen Husten.
Laut Angaben des Patienten sind die Symptome plötzlich und attackenartig aufgetreten und dauern jeweils 10 bis 15 Minuten.
Er berichtet, dass die Symptome belastungsabhängig sind und spontan wieder verschwinden.
Er gab keinen klaren Auslöser an.
Allerdings hat er kurz vorwiegend bestätigt, dass er vor drei Wochen einen Hund für seine Frau gekauft hat.
Bei der Allergienanamnese ergab sich eine Allergie gegen Tierhaare oder Katzenhaare in der Kindheit.
Die Symptome verschlimmern sich nachts und morgens früh, während sie sich bei der Arbeit oder an der frischen Luft bessern.
Außerdem erwähnt er, dass er seit drei Wochen ähnliche Beschwerden hatte.
Vegetative anamnestisch war alles unaufwendig bis auf nächtliche Attacken.
An Vorerkrankungen erwähnte er Bauchschmerzen und Diarrhobe bei Stressverdacht auf Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Er hat so genannt, wie einen Zustand nach Hepatitis A.
An Operationen sind eine Tonsillektomie und eine Appendektomie bekannt.
Der Patient nimmt Kizimea regelmäßig ein.
Er trinkt ein bis zwei Gläser Wein pro Woche.
In der Familienanamnese ergab er einen Bronzschallkarzinom bei dem Vater und Asthma bei der Mutter.
Und auch einen Verdacht auf Nierenversagen bei dem Bruder.
Er ist dialysierlich. Er ist verheiratet.
Sozialanamnistisch ist er verheiratet.
Und IT-Techniker hat keine Kinder.
Okay, was ist Ihr Verdachtdiagnose?
Nach anamnistischen Angaben habe ich den Verdacht auf ein allergisches Asthma.
Dafür sprechen paroxymale Düstner trockene Hüsten, eine Allergie gegen Katzenhaare
und das Auftreten der Beschwerden nach einem Hund bekommen.
Diese sprechen dafür.
Und differenzial diagnostisch kommen eine Pneumonie und Bronzschallkarzinom in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtsdiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Ich achte besonders bei der Oskultation auf pfeifende Atemgeräusche.
Anschließend werde ich die Vitalparameter überwachen und Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Es ist wichtig, ein EKG zu schreiben, um mögliche Herzrhythmusstörungen auszuschließen.
Der Patient leidet auch unter Herzrasen.
Im Labor würde ich Blutbild-, Entzündungsparameter, Elektrolyten, Nierenwerte, Lebenwerte, Blutgasanalyse,
und eine ganze Immunglobin A kontrollieren lassen.
Darüber hinaus werde ich eine Spirometrie mit Reversibilität testen, einen Prick-out-test und eine Röntgen-Thorax-Aufnahme durchführen.
Zudem werde ich natürlich ein pulmonologisches Konzil anfordern.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten ambulant behandeln.
Zuerst ist es natürlich sehr wichtig, Allergen zu sorgen.
Je nach Stürztherapie sollte er zu den niedrig dosierten inhalativen Corticosteroiden.
Mein erster Therapie-Vorschlag ist so.
Als Bedürfnissetherapie empfehlen Sie eine kurzwirksame Betamematik?
Ja natürlich. Das ist auch sehr wichtig.
Kurzwirksame betaswei Symptomimatik.
Sie haben gesagt, je nach Stürztherapie. Was meinen Sie Stürztherapie?
Die Haupttherapie beim Allergischen Asthma ist Stürztherapie.
Je nach Schweregrad müssen die Ärzte die Therapie einstellen.
Ja, die Schweregrad. Damit meine ich, dass die Symptome, die Beschwerden und die Objekte nach gewissenen Befunden der Patienten,
mit Hilfe von Spirometrien oder anderen Untersuchungsverfahren, auch Bildgebendeverfahren,
je nach diesen Befunden und Symptomen kann die Therapie von Ärzten einstellen.
Diese wird von Aststestufentherapie genannt.
Wie oft, haben Sie schon gefragt, wie oft der Patient Attacke tagsüber oder in der Nacht hat?
Aber sie hat nicht erwähnt. Sie weiß eher nicht.
Die Häufigkeit der Attacke ist sehr wichtig für die Stürztherapie.
Wie viele Attacke pro Woche ist wichtig für uns, um diese Therapie einzustellen.
Als operative Therapie würden Sie einen Spirometrie-Reversibility-Test durchführen.
Nicht als Therapie, sondern als Maßnahmen.
Als operative Diagon.
Was ist Spirometrie mit Reversibility-Test?
Spirometrie, damit können wir die Lungen-Dynamischen Funktionen beurteilen.
Mit dieser Lungenfunktion-Test oder Lungenfunktionüberprüfung können wir einfach sagen.
Aber mit Reversibility-Test können wir die Reversibility-Test.
Weil Asthm ist eine chronisch-entzündliche Atemweg-Krankheit.
Es gibt zwei Kernpunkte in der Pathophysiologie.
Die Schleimhaut, die überempfindliche Schleimhaut der Atemwege.
Und wegen dieser Empfindlichkeit die Verengung der Atemwege.
Mit Reversibility-Test können wir die Atemwege kurzfristig verbreiten.
Wir können mit Hilfe von Reversibility-Test die Atemwege kurzfristig verbreiten.
Das ist entscheidend und ausgeprägt in der Diagnose des Asthm.
Sie meinen, bei Asthm können die Atemwege erweitert werden.
Bei einer Werhekrankheit erweitern die Atemwege nicht.
Die COPD können die Atemwege erweitern.
Sie haben sehr gute Erkenntnisse.
Aber Sie versuchen, mit einfachen Satzen Ihre Erkenntnisse zu zeigen.
Aber mit komplizierten Satzen konnten Sie auch gut erklären.
Das war sehr gut.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit der Anamnesse.
Ich war sehr gut.
Man fragt nur den Patienten aus dem Haus.
Der Patient sagt nichts aus dem Haus.
Ich habe mir die Analyse vorgestellt.
Wenn es um Allergien geht, dann ist es so, dass ich alle Allergien habe.
Sie haben seit 3 Wochen diese Beschwerden.
Kann es einen Zusammenhang zwischen Ihrem Labrador und Ihren Beschwerden geben?
Ich wollte die Analyse in der Diagnose des Asthm.
Ich wollte den Patienten ein Weg machen.
Ich wollte ihn in der Analyse des Asthm.
Vielleicht kann man ihn in der Analyse des Asthm fragen.
Wir fragen nicht die Anamnesse.
Man muss sich die Anamnesse anregen.
Wenn man einen Lungenfunktion-Test machen will,
dann einen Prick-out-Test.
Prick-out-Test ist ein Allergietest.
Das kann ein Allergietest sein.
Das war es.
Es war sehr gut.
Danke.
Vielen Dank.
Ich möchte Sie fragen,
ob man sich die Analyse des Allergies auf den Allergien-Test aufbauen muss.
Kann man die Analyse des Allergies auf den Allergien-Test aufbauen?
Das ist nicht so.
Sie wissen es besser.
Die Analyse des Allergies ist ein Analyse des Allergies.
Das sieht man in welcher Krankheit.
Das kann man vielleicht fragen.
Aber wenn der Patient das nicht bemerkt,
dann kann man das an der Analyse beantworten.
Das wäre mir viel sinnvoller.
Man kann nicht sagen, warum man das Analyse des Allergies aufbaut.
Ich dachte schon an Allergien.
Ich wollte nicht sagen, ob ich mit einem Tier in Kontakt war.
Ich wollte das fragen.
Dann dachte ich, dass ich das beantworten kann.
Im Szenario steht, dass der Patient in einem unbekannten Ort ist.
Er sagt, dass er eine Analyse aufbaut.
Er sagt, dass er ein Kind hat.
Er steht in einem unbekannten Ort.
Dann wird er eine Analyse beantworten.
Dann wird er die Analyse beantworten.
Das kann ich besser fragen.
Wenn der Patient das beantworten kann,
dann muss er das beantworten.
Er hat das nicht beantwortet.
Ich habe es in den letzten wenigen Monaten gemacht.
Daher war es ein bisschen leer.
Ich werde dort nicht Fakarst sein, sondern nur Weita Bildung.
Ich habe auch zwei Jahre Katalogie.
Ich werde sie sagen, aber ich werde sagen, dass ich nicht Fakarst bin.
Ich werde sagen, dass ich allgemein arbeite.
Ich werde sagen, dass ich diese Idee haben möchte.
Aber Sie können es sagen.
Ich habe 3,5 Jahre Weita Bildung gemacht.
Ich habe in der Medizin gearbeitet.
Aber jetzt werde ich nicht Fakarst sein.
Ich werde jetzt nicht Fakarst sein.
Sie können es sagen.
Sie können es sagen, wie viel Weita Bildung ihr habt.
Sie können es nicht Fakarst sein, aber sie können es sagen.
Sie können es sagen, wie viel Erfarung ihr habt.
Ich habe nicht gearbeitet, deswegen habe ich es heute nicht gemacht.
Haben Sie eine CV?
Ist es ein Problem, dass ihr Fakarst ist?
Sie haben eine CV, aber ich habe nicht so viel auf mich geachtet.
Sie haben mir keine Fragen gemacht.
Ich habe in der Medizin gearbeitet.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich schon in der Türkei war.
Als Fakarstin war ich in der Türkei.
Deswegen habe ich in einer Medizin gearbeitet.
Sie haben mir keine Fragen gemacht.
Sie haben mich in Deutschland gefragt, warum sie in der Psychiatrie gearbeitet haben.
Ich habe es in der Medizin gesehen.
Wir haben nichts gemacht.
Sie hat ein Jahr in der Inere gearbeitet.
Sie hat drei Jahre in der Urologie gearbeitet.
Sie hat in der Inere gearbeitet.
Sie hat verschiedene Gründe.
Sie hat nicht die Möglichkeit, die Urologie zu machen.
Sie kann sie auch in verschiedenen Orten machen.
Sie kann die Lockbucs in den Orten der Menschen in der Medizin verpacken.
Es gibt keine Gründe, dass sie in der Türkei beginnen und enden.
Sie kann sie auch in der Medizin verpacken.
Es ist wichtig, was sie zu Beginn gesagt hat.
Sie haben eine Luftnot.
Ich habe sie gefragt.
Ich habe nichts gesagt.
Sie haben eine Luftnot in der Belastung oder in der Ruche.
Ich habe gefragt, ob sie eine Luftnot in der Belastung oder in der Ruche haben.
Sie haben keine Luftnot.
Sie können in der Attacke eine Luftnot haben.
Sie können in der Nacht eine Luftnot haben.
Sie können in der Nacht oder früh morgens in der Nacht.
Ich habe gefragt, wann sie in der Attacke sind.
Ich habe gefragt, ob sie in der Nacht oder morgens in der Nacht sind.
Oder ich habe die A Perhaps oder die Ge ложe...
Hayır!
Wenn sie in der Nacht oder morgens in der Nacht sind
können die A Vielleicht oder die Ge lesen.
Das ist effizient.
Besonderes nach Nechlihi Ataken können Sie flachlegen.
Es gibt so etwas im Asma,
besonders in Asma-Atakler,
in der Nacht zu schlafen,
in der Flach-Ligen.
Deswegen besonderes nach Nechlihi Ataken können Sie flachlegen.
Oder, brakun Sie ein paar Kissen.
Das habe ich auch gefragt.
Dann zu Hüsten.
Dies ist etwas wie,
dass man immer mit dem Luftnoten auftaucht.
Dann ist es so,
dass man sich von der Hüste ausführt.
Oder mit dem Auswurf.
Ich habe da sagen lassen,
dass man von der Hüste ausführt,
oder mit dem Auswurf.
Dann ist es so,
dass man,
Sie können sie auch so fragen.
Sie können sie so fragen.
So kann man sie so fragen.
So.
Ich habe das auch um sie gefragt.
Dann, um meine Einreden zu machen, habe ich Fiba, um Pneumonien einzubinden.
Die Erkrankung ist sehr wichtig.
Man kann den Lungenembolie auch als eine Anwendung bezeichnen.
Das waren die Fragen.
Wie gehen wir wieder?
Wir untersuchen die Symptome des Patienten.
Wir untersuchen Lufnot, Hüste,
ob es einen Moment gibt, ob es nicht,
ob es in der Ataklage kommt, ob es in der Belastung oder in der Ruhe kommt.
Wenn es in der Ataklage kommt,
wann ist es, ob es Abend oder Abend ist,
ob es das erste Mal ist, ob es es schon mal gibt,
wie viele Ataklage es bis jetzt gibt,
ob es die Gipäseine 5 Tümpel auslösen,
ob es die Anwendung für diese gibt,
das sind die Fragen.
Nach der Ataklage, Könöse, Flachlage,
Wenn Sie das fragen wollen,
können Sie die Atemgeröße, Fastoraxe,
Vegetative Anamnese, Fibers,
Schützelfrohs, Nachschweiz, Kassiweiß,
Schweißausbrüche,
Apathit, Gewichtveränderung und Schlaf,
Hüsten, Lungen und Brust,
die Sie zu Beginn gefragt haben,
dann das Gasoenothestensystem,
Übelkeit, Erbrechen, Stülgang,
Vasalasen,
und dann, wie ich gesagt habe,
das Wichtigste hier ist,
wenn es um Allergien geht,
die Allergien zu fragen.
Hatten Sie in lestes Zeit Kontakt zu einem Tier oder zu einem Katz?
Das war mein erster klassischer Befragung.
Die Reaktionen hier sind,
die Reaktionen hier sind,
dass es nicht ein Kinderzahler gibt.
Ja das tut mir leid.
Ich habe sie verurteilt, dass sie eine Entscheidung getroffen haben, eine künstliche Befürchtung
zu verursachen oder zu probieren.
Ich habe viele Menschen kennengelernt, dass sie auf viel mal Künstliche Befürchtung
verursacht und dann könnten sie ein Baby haben.
Ich hoffe, dass sie auch ein Baby haben.
So etwas.
Ich bin sehr veräußert, dass ihr keine Kinder haben könntet, aber ihr habt
nicht so einen Krebs verpasst.
Aber ich bin nicht so, wie sie es nicht wahrgenommen haben, dass sie
nicht so einen Krebs verursacht haben.
Ich bin sehr veräußert, dass sie keine Kinder haben, aber sie haben
eine künstliche Befürchtung.
Ich habe viele Menschen kennengelernt, die mit einer künstlichen Befürchtung
verursacht haben.
Ich bin sehr veräußert, dass sie keine Kinder haben, aber sie haben
Die beiden sind in der Form von Ronchus, die Beziehung zu Brämen und Gimen.
Rassal Geroushe, die beiden sind in der Form von Ronchus, die Beziehung zu Brämen und Gimen.
Ich glaube, dass die beiden gleich die gleiche Sache sind. Ich habe es so verstanden.
Ich glaube, dass die beiden auch in Asma sind.
Also, Chetin-Holger weiß es besser.
Die beiden sind in der Form von Ronchus, die beiden sind in der Form von Gimen und Brunnen.
Ich habe es so verstanden. Ich dachte, dass ich das so sagen würde.
Sümera-Holger, wenn wir Sie umsetzen, können Sie uns diese Weiterdiagnostik und Therapie-Scheine in der Form von Türkisch verbreiten?
Okay.
Ich werde versuchen, das zu sagen, wie ich es sage.
Ich habe die gleiche Stelle gesagt. Ich habe die gleiche Stelle gesagt.
Ich habe die gleiche Stelle gesagt.
In der Dokumentation habe ich die gleiche Stelle geschrieben.
In Teil 2.
In Teil 3.
Die gleiche Stelle.
Ich glaube, es ist sehr schwer, eine Weiterdiagnostik zu machen.
Es ist nicht so ähnlich wie etwas.
Das ist ein chronisch-obstruktives Pulmener-Siege.
Er trinkt nicht mal ein Zigaret.
Deswegen ist er sehr nackig.
Ich habe mich lange nicht verstanden, was ich als Differential-Tanze sagen würde.
Ich kann es nicht erinnern, aber ich glaube, ich kann es als Pinomoni- und Broschalkarsinom-Diagnostik sagen.
So.
Was habe ich gesagt?
Ich werde die weitere Anklage auf die Sperrkörper-Unterzucht, die Vorbereitung, die Digital-Parameter und das Blut-Food abnehmen.
Natürlich auch ein EKG schreiben.
Ich werde die Blutbild-Anzündung parametern für die Z-Reaktiv-Proteine, Nieren, Leber, Elektrolyte, insgesamt die gesamte Immunglöbelin E, Blutgasanalyse, Bestimmungen.
Als Apparativ werde ich Röntgen-Thorax-Aufnahme, Spirometry mit Reversibilität-Test und Prig-Haut-Test durchführen und einen Konsul in der Abteilung für Pulmonologie anfordern.
So habe ich gesagt.
Ich werde die Körper-Unterzucht-Aufnahme beachten, ich werde das beachten.
Hier habe ich es nicht gesagt.
Wenn sie fragen, sage ich es.
Ich mache das mit allen Patienten so.
Ich verändern ein paar Dinge im Labor, ein paar Dinge im Apparativ, und nur den Konsul, den Namen der Stelle.
Das wird sehr hilfreich für die Serien.
Ich sage das nicht so sehr, aber ich kann das sagen, weil das so ist.
Was man bei der Körper-Unterzucht beachten kann, ist, ob es besonders bei Oskiltation, Atemgeräuschen gibt, wie es mit dem Knie und Brüsten vorhanden ist.
Ich habe gesagt, dass es vorhanden ist, ob es mit den Knie und Brüsten vorhanden ist.
Oder ob es mit Sionoz oder nicht.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich mit diesen Dingen beachten kann.
Ich habe die Patienten so gemacht, dass sie eine niedrige Dosis der Inhalation haben.
Ich werde eine Konsul in der Abteilung für Pulmonologie anfordern.
Wenn sie fragen, was da sein kann, dann habe ich mir selbst festgestellt, was ich sagen soll.
Ich habe die Erste Therapie gesagt.
Ich habe die Therapie von Schütte, die einig ist, und die die zwei auch.
Aber Schütte 3, Schütte 4, Schütte 5, die Therapie wird komplex.
Was kann da nötig sein?
Das war mein Plan, wenn ich diese Therapie bekomme.
Ich wollte es so sagen.
Ich habe die Erste Therapie gesagt.
Ja, danke.
Ich hoffe, dass wir das in den restlichen Fakten auch so machen.
Das wird für uns auch schön, wie ein Anerkanal.
Und es wird schön, was wir für uns in die Art machen können.
Wenn es Zeit bleibt, dann machen wir das.
Vielen Dank, Meira.
Danke.
Das war's für heute.
Ich wünsche euch alles Gute.
Bis morgen.